So now, we know that everything we think and do happens because of nerve cells.
As it turns out, nerve cells are not alone. There are actually two main types
of cells in the central nervous system. The glial cells and the neurons, or the
nerve cells. The glial cells, as seen here, provide structural support. They
support the efficient communication between neurons. In addition, they also
help my removing cellular debris. Glial actually means glue in Greek. It helps
to hold the central nervous system together. The glial cells also help form the
blood-brain barrier, and play a role in the control of breathing. The neurons
are cells that process and transmit information in the nervous system. They
receive information, they integrate that information, and then they generate
messages. There are approximately ten billion neurons in the human brain. And
even though they're located very close together, most of them don't actually
touch. Each neuron has about ten thousand connections to other neurons. Which
allows for literally trillions and trillions of neural connections. This makes
the brain one of the most complex structures we know.